[Music]
cancer is a major cause of death
throughout europe
screening or the testing of people who
do not display any symptoms makes it
possible to detect cancers at an early
stage
this increases treatment options and can
save lives
yet coverage of the target population
ranges across the eu from six percent to
90 for breast cancer screening
and from about 25 percent to 80 percent
for cervical cancer screening this is
unacceptable
europe's beating cancer plan proposes a
new eu supported cancer screening scheme
to help member states increase access
reduce inequalities and ensure that 90
percent of the eu population who qualify
for breast cervical and colorectal
cancer screenings are offered screening
by 2025.
the existing council recommendations are
now 20 years old and much has advanced
in the meantime
the european commission is proposing to
update the recommendations to take into
account new evidence and technologies
and to expand organized cancer screening
programs to include lung prostate and
under certain circumstances gastric
cancer screening
this should help further reduce disease
burden and mortality
[Music]
you